[Musique]
ce triangle géant tracé sur la calotte
terrestre nous avons tous appris à
l'école qu'il était l'immense continent
africain construit sur un cap dont le
nom invite à l'optimisme le Cap de Bonne
Espérance au 17e siècle des bateaux à
voile tels des oiseaux migrateurs
déposai au Cap ce qui furent ces
premiers colons les
Hollandais
celui-ci Peter stuesant vient nous
rappeler qu'à peu près à la même époque
fut fondée la Nouvelle Amsterdam qui
devait devenir la ville de New
York Yan van rbec peint d'après nature
puis coulé en bronze par la
postérité débarquait au cap avec une
poignée d'homme le 6 avril
1652 il fut le premier à hisser le
drapeau hollandais sur le sol
sud-africain alors il faut le dire assez
peu fréquenté en dehors des
naufrages mais l'heure des pionnier est
passé celle des touristes est venu le
soleil les attend au coin du
cap et avec le soleil une étrange
montagne appelée montagne de la Table et
qui ne connaît qu'une nappe celle des
nuages elle paraît avoir été découpée à
1000 m d'altitude à grand coup de
couteau
fantasque la table reste éternellement
desservie le paysage est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dessous au Cap comme ailleurs on visite
d'abord le château il a été Châteaufort
aujourd'hui il capitule sans condition
devant le premier touriste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venu le soleil est partout et d'abord
sur ses grappes sur ses vignes sans
doute dans le cœur de ceux qui préparent
le vin à la manière traditionnelle et
sûrement sur la langue de celui qu'il
[Musique]
goûte les Africans d'Urs ont été élevés
dans une religion extrêmement
rigoriste ils en ont gardé la lettre
quelquefois l'esprit en tout cas
[Musique]
l'église personne ne connaît l'origine
de ce carnaval à ombrelle et chapeau
claque mais tout le monde sait qu'il
marque pour les gens de couleur un
nouvel an quelque peu
gesticulant
[Musique]
la République sud-africaine a résolu le
problème de la séparation des pouvoirs
exécutifs législatifs et judiciair en
leur attribuant chacun une capitale
distincte les lois se font au
[Musique]
cap mais une nature généreuse elle
distribue à profusion le soleil la mer
plages les montagnes les dépliants vous
diront le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reste
[Musique]
à la pointe extrême du Cap l'océan
Indien et l'océan Atlantique se disent
en permanence un tumultueux
bonjour Le Homar prêché ici par tonne
chaque
année finit glorieusement
cardinal
à quoi bon vous dire que l'Afrique du
Sud rè dans son admirable magasin de
décor naturel tout ce qui peut faire
grimper l'alpiniste
ou rouler la voiture enchanter le
botaniste
ou affoler le photographe qui joue les
bourdons parmi les fleurs des champs
d'ailleurs vous allez voir tout cela
[Musique]
l'autruche a donné son nom à une
politique et a une ville spécialisée
dans la production de plumes bien
sû voici l'animal dans l'exercice de ses
[Musique]
fonction
ici le déplumage est systématique une
autruche un client ces tas de plumes ont
été adjugé 50000 livres sterling à qui
si la plume d'autruche se porte moins en
ville elle se porte toujours
[Musique]
ailleurs
et quand on élève des autruches et qu'on
a de
l'imagination on organise des concours
et on fait défiler les partants dont la
démarche présente une remarquable
similitude
[Musique]
la compétition amuse énormément le
Badeau un peu moins l'oiseau et pas du
tout le joquet l'autruche tient très
bien la route le joquet tient bien moins
l'autruche que dire encore du cap on
commence à y greffer des cœurs c'est bon
signe